-Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell
gave an interview
to conservative radio host
Hugh Hewitt
during which he claimed
that the Trump administratio
was too distracted
by the impeachment hearing
to properly respond
to the coronavirus threat,
which brings us
to a segment we call
"Really?! With Seth and Amy.
-Really, Mitch McConnell?
You haunted corncob doll.
The impeachment trial
was too distracting? Really?
You realize that trial
ended back on February 5th
and your boy was still out her
calling the virus a hoax
until about
a week and a half ago.
I'm not surprised
you're trying to rewrite history
since you've made it clear
you're not happy
with some of the outcomes.
I mean, really?
-Really? Yeah.
Mitch, you think your boy Trum
was too distracted to thin
about the coronavirus?
He was on trial for sellin
the country down the river
and he was still out there
holding rallies
and playing more golf
than a San Diego dentist.
He's a multitasker.
He's a New Yorker.
Back in the day,
he could bankrupt
three companies in the afternoon
and still have the energy
to yell at his housekeeper
when she set
his Tic Tacs out wrong.
He's a self-proclaimed geniu
who can hold
many complex thoughts
in his head at the same time
Really?!
-Really? And really, Mitch
You Albino river toad.
We all know why
you support Donald Trump,
and it's not because
you respect him.
It's because
having Trump in charge
is like having
a hungover substitute teacher.
I mean, really,
you get to buck the system
break every rule,
and steal everything you can
and there's no one to answer t
because he fell asleep the
second he hit play on the VCR.
You're like those people
who move into their
dead grandparents' house
and keep cashing their
Social Security checks,
only not as classy.
I mean, really?
-Really?
Oh, and, by the way, Mitch
when Trump heard
about your little comment,
he said, I don't think
I would have done any better
had I not been impeached."
So even Trump does not buy
your dumb argument.
That must feel like gettin
a note back in sixth grade
with the "no" box checked.
You know, all right.
Don't worry about it, Mitch.
You're gonna be okay. Really
It's not the first time
people like you
didn't get what they wanted.
-Really?
-Really!
Well, this has been
another segment of
"The world feels like it's
ending and no one is in charge."
-No, Amy.
This has been "Really?!"
-Are you sure that this
is not a segment called
"The world feels like it's
ending and no one is in charge"?
-No, no. It's just "Really?!
-Really?
-Really.
-All right. Really! Really
Virtual high five!
-This has been
"Really?! With Seth and Amy.